hi my name is Daniel Shan ski I'm an
intern here on the Android team at
Google and today I'll be talking about
some ListView animation insertions so in
this specific demo what we're going to
be doing is adding a day adding a new
object to the 0th index of the data set
associated with a ListView and an
animating that solved downwards into it
as that's going to happen all the other
items in the list you're going to make
space for the new cell animate downwards
as the new cell animates back in and
then just as a cool little extra part to
the animation we're going to have an
image that's part of the cell animate in
to its correct location as the new
element is being added to being added to
it
some of the important things to know for
this animation some of the few tricks
and problems I encountered is the fact
that when you and when you change the
data set some of the objects that you
may need may no longer be available
after after Laird has occurred so what
you need to do is you need to take a
snapshot of all the of all the items
before you modify the data set so that
after you modify the data set if you no
longer have a reference to some of these
items you can still animate them out of
the bounds of the ListView because you
won't need them after that anymore so
jumping straight to the demo all we have
here is a button little roundview to its
left the ListView is completely empty
clicking add row animate creates a new
cell and animates it downwards and we
can add as many elements as you want
they'll start looping and as you can see
it animates downwards and all the
elements unless you're underneath
animate down as that happens you cannot
of course scroll the list if you want to
but the interesting to note as well is
that even though each of these images is
part of the data set associated with
that item in the list with that exact
cell what we're doing is animating the
image from outside the bounds of the
ListView into its correct location in
the ListView where it's that word then
stays and persists as you scroll the
list here afterwards so then looking at
the code we can go into insertion
ListView which is an object that extends
lists you where you can insert these new
items and after a lot of boilerplate
code that you can look over later
the main logic happens in AD bro so
firstly what we need to do here is first
get a reference to our adapter and
afterwards what I'm gonna do is keep
track of the balance and the draw balls
of all the items that are in my listing
before the data sent before the data set
change took place so I'm gonna low I'm
gonna loop through all my visible cells
and I'm gonna take a screenshot of every
single cell I'm gonna store that I'm
also going to take retrieve the balance
of every single cell and stored that in
a corresponding hash map as well so now
regardless of whether or not those cells
are still there after the data sent data
set change has taken place I'll still
have a reference to them then when you
move down here I create I actually add
the new object to my data set and at a
stable ID corresponding to that thing
corresponding to that item because in my
array adapter I've specified true for
stable IDs so that means I need to make
sure that a new stable ID is added to
that element then I notify data set
change which will request the layout on
behalf of the ListView but since I've
wanted to animate one of the one of the
common tricks that have been used for a
lot of these animations is using a non
preacher listener so once again you on
measure and on layout have already been
called all the final values for all the
for all the widgets in the list
contained within the ListView have
already been calculated but have not
been drawn to the screen yet so this is
where any custom animations you want to
do you can do them here since you
already have a reference to all the
final values so going into on free draw
we remove the listener and create a new
array where we're gonna a new ArrayList
so we're gonna store all our animations
so firstly since I know that I'm adding
a new cell to the 0th index I that's the
view that I'm gonna want to use for for
a lot of my calculations and animations
I I retrieved and then uh what I'm
creating is creating a copy image view
because I can actually can't actually
animate the view that I need from within
the cell from outside the balance and
put it where I need to or what I'm gonna
do is create a new copy image ooh that
has the same content as that
as the cell itself as the image you in
the cell itself and then I'll just
animate into place and then get rid of
one I don't need her anymore
so when I'm animating a new row one of
the other things I do is just animate
the text associated with that cell fade
it in as it animates down and in regard
to the image there's some add that I
need to do to determine where it starts
and word has to end but after all that
is gone after all of that is done all
you need to really know is that the
image you in the cell has to be set to
invisible while the animation is
happening while the copy imagery has to
be visible or I add a I use an overshoot
interpolator
and scale the X and the y properties of
the imagery just to get this little cool
popping like effect and then I animate
it into place in the new cell view and
once that's done I can then I can later
at the end of animation get rid of my
copy image view and set the visibility
of my normal view back to normal so
scrolling down furthermore this is once
the data set change has already been
modified so then I'll loop through all
my visible children of the ListView at
this point and I'm gonna have there
gonna be two types of children that I
can't that I'll be you're working with
those that have those that have a
corresponding balance in the in the
hashmap I stored originally and those
that don't if they do have a
corresponding balance then what that
means is that they were visible
delisting before the animation and
they're also visible in the list view
after animation so all I need to do is
create an object animator that
translates it from its old position to
its new position if I don't have that
start balance that what that means is
that this is in the context of this of
this demo that there's only one cell
that can have this configuration it
means that it wasn't in the listing
before but it is in the ListView after
and since we're only inserting one new
item into the ListView this has to be
the one in the zero index and since I
also want to animate this I I do a a
little bit of math and determining what
the height is with the divider Highwood
divider height is and then I do the same
thing and animate it's why it's
translation why property to get it from
where I want where it originally would
have been to where I wanted to be after
after the layout then of course since I
don't need these anymore
for my hashmap and then scrolling down
here if I loop through a key set of all
the items that are left in my hash map
what this means is that these are items
that are wore in the ListView prior to
the data set change but are no longer
visible in the ListView after a data set
change so these involve items that have
been moved outside the bounds of the
ListView due to the due to the insertion
of the new item and since these items
are no longer contained within the list
container what I need to do is use the
bitmap drawables which I've captured
from before overlaid them on top of my
list view and then animate that our
bounds as if they were still on there
were still in the ListView
there's since I'm animating the bounds
it's important to know that every single
time the bounds were changed I need to
invalidate my view in order for that
portion I'll dalish you to get updated
and in order to make that a little more
efficient i-i-i call invalidate with a
rect inside of it such that I don't
validate
Riaan validate the whole ListView and
redraw the whole thing every single time
only one of the bitmap drawables has
animated so I set up those animations
for every bit of drawable and I also
added to this array that I have emcell
bitmap drawables which I will make note
of in a second and I add the animation
to my animator set III animated all this
together and then at the end I do all
the default things like make my list you
enable again get rid of make the make
the image view in the actual self
visible again made a copy image you
invisible and things like that so now
here in this patch draw this is where
I'm going to use that array of all the
bitmap drawables corresponding to the
items that disappeared I'm going to loop
through all of them and draw them onto
the canvas every single time dispatch
draw is called one of the important
things to note here is that I'm checking
if the size is zero just to make sure
that there are no extra allocations done
using this using the new Java for object
for loops and looping down farther more
scrolling down furthermore there's just
some checks I'm checking whether in
want to animate in the new image or not
so for example if I were to scroll down
here and then at a row I'm not at the
top so I'm not going to be adding
animating in that image or if I'm up
here that new image you will be
animating down down here there's just
some more code of how I'm taking
snapshots of the list of the ListView
cells and how animate them into place as
well as how I'm doing how I'm getting
absolute locations on the screen what I
want to know where that extra image view
needs to be when I decide where to
animate it to so that's pretty much it -
how you can insert new cells and animate
their animator addition to your listing
thanks